welcome to the longest staring contest
of your life
you're about to go seven days without
blinking
what device would keep your eyes forced
open
how long would it take before the pain
becomes unbearable
and why
might you never be able to see
again this is what if and here's what
would happen if you didn't blink for a
week
blinking keeps your eyeballs lubricated
and clear of particles
without this reflex that happens every
four seconds
you'd have to deal with very dry very
painful eyes
when you blink you release a tear film
that helps keep the surface of your
eyeball smooth
this smooth surface also allows light to
properly focus so you don't have blurry
vision
huh
who said that
and since there are no blood vessels
that reach your cornea your eyes are
dependent on this film for oxygen
plus it contains enzymes that fight
bacteria and prevent infection
so without blinking for a week
how soon would your eyes get blurry
dry
and riddled with bacteria
for the next
168 hours you won't be allowed to blink
at all
forget about relying on willpower to
beat this reflex
you'd need some serious help keeping
those beepers peeled
how about a lid speculum
yeah it might look like it belongs in a
torture chamber but
this device is usually used for surgery
and it would be your best bet
just place a ring under your upper and
lower eyelid
simple right
yeah good luck trying to blink now
start the countdown
after just four seconds you'd be
fighting off the natural instinct to
blink and
oh what a fight you're in for
with no way to properly lubricate your
eyes
they'd begin to dry out
every second they would get redder and
redder
this would be due to tiny blood vessels
expanding on their surface
once you take away that protective film
of tears
your vision would blur as dust and
particles settle in
your eyeballs would have an uneven
surface
light wouldn't even be able to pass
through
you'd be in a real pickle now
more moisture would be evaporating from
the eyes then is being replenished
the burning would become a gritty
stinging feeling
and it's gonna get worse
you'd be absolutely desperate to blink
now
it would feel as if forever has passed
but it's only been a few minutes
so
buckle up the challenge ain't over yet
to distract yourself you could go out
for a walk but
guess what yeah that'd be a bad idea too
you've got no way of protecting your
eyes from the uv rays of the sun
totally exposed this could burn your
corneas and leave you temporarily blind
for up to 48 hours
all you'd want to do now is get some
sleep
not so fast
there's a reason sleeping is nicknamed
shut eye
yeah of course your eyes would need to
close for that
your frustration combined with the
exhaustion of insomnia would add to the
already serious pain and discomfort
you'd be experiencing
hopefully you'd be one of the 20 of
people who can sleep with their eyes
open
with each passing minute the risk of
infection would increase
your eyelids would be itching you'd have
mucus oil and skin cells being
discharged
i doubt that would relieve you in any
way
you would also suffer from the lack of
oxygen going to your corneas
leading to corneal hypoxia
can be a common complication for people
with contact lenses
but for you
it's just another crisis to add to your
list
your already manic looking eyes would
swell and if left untreated
could result in the death of cells
this would lead to long-term damage
now through sheer will and determination
you'd make it to the end of the week so
you'd be miserable to say the least
you'd be swollen in agony and
essentially blind
i'm legally blind i can see barely
a long road to recovery awaits you
following this staring contest
at the end of day seven you'd finally be
allowed to blink
something you should have done over 100
000 times already
and that
could be the most painful moment of all
you'd close your eyes and a week's worth
of dirt and grime would scratch over
your corneas
with all the nerve endings they contain
this would be absolutely excruciating
now if there's one silver lining you'd
now finally be able to close your eyes
and get some sleep
unless
you couldn't sleep anymore
but
that's a story
or another
what if
[Music]